nice all right hi there welcome to the
Friday games review i am your host Ian
knee Lewthwaite no we totally switched
off right away list anymore wow that's
it that's okay yeah yeah actually your
according to the titles your Dan Galpin
and I'm you I know I know ah hold on
okay dude don't complain on YouTube
we've heard it all before yeah exactly
yeah if I did that you know why cuz I'm
left-right challenged okay it's because
I come from a mirror universe that makes
sense that makes sense yeah that would
explain a lot actually actually I'm
pretty sure dance from the mirror
universe cuz he has the Spock evil twin
beard going dude that's not Spock evil
beard that's the plantation owned a
beard that's is yeah see ya this
shouldn't say Dan Galpin i should say
Colonel Dan gail katz right accident I
do I guess it does look kind of like
Colonel Sanders doesn't it it does
indeed my friend his younger years
before before I came up at 11 herbs and
spices all right right it was back to
nine herbs and spices like that yeah
spanning of herbs and spices and
discovered the other two in this let's
bring in our special guest special get
oh yes absolutely especially cuz every
little guess I know all right like so
today we are drinking a hoax trottin
quarter hmm which may or may not be good
I don't know all right you can see it's
the bottle is resealable so you know we
don't drink it all right that's it
that's a useless expense that's pretty
needless right there we have some great
apps today you know dan dan & Co talked
last time and they're like you know
screw this whole theme thing that's
right we're just gonna go with whatever
the viewers watch and by viewers we mean
whoever had enough friends to nominate
something and get it voted up we've got
some good stuff today I think oh and we
also have our new high-tech title system
watch this we so that's what we're going
to watch that's what we're gonna talk
about today mm-hmm
and I have to oh yeah yeah I'm supposed
to be sitting over here yeah and I know
like evidence is all all challenging all
right now we're totally good we're
totally Gibby's have less space in
borger so we're talking we're going to
be talking about pearls deluxe a Surrey
tower defense sacristy RPG potentia and
offroad legends and that's a lot to get
through so let's start up our super
duper sports center title sequence okay
well that's that's all there is all
right but but I totally downloaded the
demo version of after effects last night
yeah so if I get some time over the
weekend there might who knows what
amazing things might happen there might
be some amazing cool stuff alright I've
now put them on in the right order here
yeah beautifu there we are all right
indeed okay so let's start with pearls
deluxe now pearls deluxe I is a game
that reminds me a lot of something I've
seen before did we play pearls the non
deluxe version at some point or III
don't know I just certain I thought you
were going to say the pearls deluxe has
got the most washed out looking featured
rack that is an issue yeah you may um a
lot of things about this feature graphic
are good yeah it's definitely legible
but yeah it's it looks ladies not only
does it look washed out but it also
looks like it's just been scaled up
rather than scaled down which oh really
yeah well that that may actually be the
my fault I may have actually put it
under nice i looked at it on google okay
it's kind of fuzzy looking so alright so
obviously a great feature graphic is
important but it's particularly
important if you want to get featured
yes now let's talk about Pearl slice the
pearls deluxe ended up being a really
fun game I think absolutely do you play
it much it's oh it's a doesn't support
yeah we're at we're gonna play rich put
this down I think plant plant like that
just so we don't jiggle the hdmi because
because it's yep
oh that's funny I put it down in an
angle and then I looked at this and I
thought oh no how wait how is that an
angle that's just the way it works so
yeah so prolix is kind of a it's a
slight twist on your typical bubble
popping game yeah actually I think it's
pretty pretty significant sweet twist
you know we're basically what you have
to do is create sequences of paths that
that have to cover all the dots you can
all of the the pearls that are the same
color that are touching each other but
also have to be in a line that goes
straight through without any turns or
diagonals so like it's impossible to
pick up oh well without any backtracking
yeah so for instance this hon look you
can't do can we cello in there then they
have really really cute sound effects
what we can't play because of the man
yeah all right exactly oh it's a big one
over there on that there is oh oh yeah
nice okay yeah so what I like about this
twist is that it's not just a change in
the way it's you know played from
mechanics level it does affect your
strategy deeply yeah absolutely and it's
you can definitely screw yourself up and
get to a point where there's just
nothing you can pop anymore if you're
not careful also there's a timer
throughout the game as we just saw so
you know just some general comments
about the game 1 this is a you know
example of what happens when you don't
actually look at the ad on a tablet
device yeah yeah your ad network is
probably not going to be happy with you
for that why I think it's more of it you
probably people aren't even know what
that is and maybe they'll get some
clicks that way i don't know but i
suspect to get fewer clicks if people
can't read the ad but you know you never
yeah i never know what really works with
these things yeah that's definitely one
thing to look at now what is the share
button do I didn't actually try it I'm a
little bit terrified well that is a
share in time Charenton that's good um
but you've also got a facebook button
which takes you to the website yeah
we're not super thrilled with that and
then let me be really clear it has
nothing to do with the particular social
network if this was a google plus button
we would feel exactly the same way it's
just there's already a share intent and
adding extra stuff on there especially
something that's going to take you out
of the game and launch a web browser
which is almost always going to take a
long time to start up and it uses
battery and it uses data yeah why yeah
it's one of those things where it's also
it's also signed another question
whether you want to actually launch it
in the external browser launch it in a
webview you know I don't even know what
you want to do yeah it's like and the
thing is part of it part of it is the
fact that there's already the share
intent available but I understand that
you know there's a difference between
liking something or plus wanting
something and sharing it but if you'll
if you look at how these buttons work on
websites when you +1 something or when
you like something that's a single
action you just press that button and
you're done it's supposed to be a very
very lightweight action but here you've
changed something that's supposed to be
lightweight and you've made it extremely
heavy weight exactly exactly so that's
completely agree with you basically I
liked you when i press that button but
by the times of web browser launched I
no longer liked you exactly you just
have to be just that much more
enthusiastic about the game to actually
get to the like anxiety it is a pretty
good game though it is it is I'm you
know in general it behaved reasonably
well you know did nothing nothing
nothing wrong with this all right so you
know in terms of in terms of what
happens when you press the back key here
you know you know reasonable now you
know again it looks like a dialogue and
there we are back at our home screen so
not too bad now in sharp contrast to
that let's take a look at our next game
so a cert our defense uh I have to admit
it really got my hopes up well you are
at our depends I love tower defense and
when I this I thought who purchased like
tons and tons of idea items and radiant
defends you know I purchase every item
in radians offense absolutely got all
the upgrades I would love to have a game
like that again i still play radiant
defense sometimes i'm up to i'm up to 13
million exactly so you have the right
reviewer here for this
is what I was saying and then i looked
at the feature graphic and I'm like that
looks pretty promising that's got some
nice debt it's a little dated but not
bad yeah it's you know I look at this
and I'm like oh hell yeah a story TD is
an awesome new strategic tower defense
game filled with action a circuit our
defense is an awesome new tower defense
game okay ah it's a unique strategy game
and full of action you'll never a dull
moment or playing it you mean my other
tower defense games but a Surrey is the
ultimate tower defense game and bring
you to places with a new unique story
mode so I was excited people have the
idea that if you repeat a keyword a
whole bunch in the description it's more
likely to be like found by us that's not
actually true no it's not it's actually
kind of less likely because we think
it's spam yeah but here's the thing the
general thing you know don't do it I
don't one could forgive me for getting
my hopes up once I read this now that's
already I read it and I looked at it why
are they spelling tower defense multiple
ways if in the description maybe maybe
my guess is they're from India and there
they've still got a bunch of leftovers
from their former British Masters well
just was into me state they spilled it
both ways and i was thinking yeah what I
make sure they got both keywords or
something like that possible yeah but
our our system is smart I don't think
that's actually this is yes and it in
any case I got to the part about the
story plot and I'm like oh story plot
and then it says the story is about a
hero and rose they traveled to face of
time they start to like each other and
like that's mmm and then I read the
reviews and here's where it got
interesting for me okay I read the
reviews and I noticed that they had a
very good rating okay I also noticed
that there are two reviews left by kind
of random people with sort of just you
know random names I that say this game
is not worth your time it's absolute
rubbish okay there are then three
reviews that are extremely complimentary
all of which have I Indian names ah well
maybe it's just in time designed to
appeal to a demographic that is
completely possible or it might very
well be that the dude in here
fans exactly it could be you know not
that happy if you have a small enough
sample set your you know friends can
actually you know alter the the yeah so
what I'm I guess what I'm saying is if
if you're gonna pack reviews with your
friends make sure that they've got like
distinctive instead of just you know a
me like they like the same family name
that's a tip-off anyway let's take a
look at the game I now the thing about
tower defense oh now this is where it
goes wrong can you take my overlay off
beautiful see that's what we get for
having a professional end you can get
rid of us actually to momentarily
because I think people should screen
without our face it no we're back there
are some you did say momentarily
uh unfortunately they're they're further
behind me that I was covered with these
gigantic fake Comic Sans bubbly in a
sort of 1995 way buttons which is just
horrible and they've got their own take
on the blink tag so kudos there there's
also something on the title screen that
says when experiencing lag in Game
considered to turn off music and or
sound by clicking sound icons I I
thought if those the icons here or those
the icons in the game I think this may
be there I don't care I don't care at
all this is an ugly title screen fixed
it you need to fix that you've also
reused the exact same set of nine
patches apparently for or is that even
nine patch as I'm not sure for these
buttons on the left and right hand side
of the screen where they look very
inappropriate big button on the left
that says back is is kind of pointless
is this is one of those cases like we
said that you know just because you got
yourself like a demo copy of photoshop
and you know how to use the gradient
tool does not mean that you're gonna
make a beautiful glass you I it's it's a
lot easier to put together something
that looks like that i'm totally betting
on the game right now thanks again uh
yeah it anyways it doesn't have a cheesy
embossing effect at least they have a
start here which is using camp this is
they have a start here which is nice
because i wouldn't have known although i
will say that the blue arrow here below
the start here button is almost
invisible i do kinda like the effect
that pixilation effective to get going
over there so this is kind of cool um
definitely needs some a little bit of
thinking about fonts i actually i would
just write like it to be rendering the
font on the device right that that would
help that would make that actually make
a huge difference in all of these things
it just makes it you pre an appeal to
tell out there and
but the phone no it's interesting that I
did I I actually that slip past me
mm-hmm and this whole time I've been
thinking well I guess it makes sense
that the fonts look crappy because I
must just not be looking at it at the
resolution of his author okay but no
they they actually baked these fonts in
yeah so this is great it's just again
you need you need to have a designer on
this you know I'm okay this is again
some really you know here for instance
we've got phones which is cool so we've
got a lot of text here I that is not
well planned out for instance resources
the word is actually broken in yeah
right um I I guess I don't even know
what to say about this other than wow
yeah when you actually get into the game
again we've got a weird mix of somewhat
attractive graphics and things that
aren't attractive at all it's not at all
apparent how I start the game I seem to
remember that I finally clicked like
over here and then I you know I'm gonna
build some stuff here it seems like it
seems like it was an amazing amount of
text to not tell you anything useful
yeah about them oh I guess you don't
have anymore more funds left right right
uh now in this case there's a couple of
things that I have to object to um so
the individual pieces of art are okay
the animation is disappointing the the
death graphics are kind of cool if
you've got a little explosion but you'll
notice they don't remove the sprite
until after the explosion animation
finishes which yay completely EPA
motivate the sprite out during the
explosion at least yeah absolutely yeah
in general you should be what you really
want to do is take your sprite get rid
of the the unit sprite as soon as it
dies and replace it with something else
whether it's the explosion or
or something you know something that
shows it breaking up or something that
fades out or whatever yeah I also you
know these laser beams I'm not buying
them they're not exciting these things
aren't taking damage in any obvious way
even the health bars are very very hard
to see and buy some I like little
explosions when they reach your base now
that's kind of cool it is cool but it
would be great i mean they they
completely cover the unit why isn't the
unit being removed under cover of that
explosion because it's odd yeah uh it's
odd because a lot of these things seem
really easy to do right yeah it's like
you this is fairly looking you forget
you got this really cool little water
effect there on the other side which I'm
sure someone spent you know yeah a bit
of time actually thinking about doing
yeah I mean it feels like they've got
some some talent but it's just very very
uneven you know when i played this on my
Nexus 7 it actually had an interesting
bug where they would reach the the heart
here which is the end point and actually
just turn around and go back they
wouldn't die until they get all the way
back wow that seems like that actually
requires some really interesting pathing
yeah that's that's a cool but ah yeah
yeah exactly so wonder if it's good huh
essentially yeah this this isn't
grabbing me it's also I it starts out
very difficult mmm and continues to be
difficult and then doesn't really give
you any payoff for that difficulty so I
have to admit that while I love tower
defense games and I really wanted to
like this one I didn't play past the
first level no so if you second levels
awesome you know like was it to me I'm
hoping this story actually kind of go
continues on I don't want the story some
guy falls in love with a girl I hate
those things stories alright alright
alright so there that guy's that's that
there's a town it sounds are as the core
of a lot of a lot of ideas there that
could be polished up and yakking now
this this is probably a good time to
mention that our good friend producer
alex is online watching the YouTube
video I had to check because last time
here's like get his email and stuff yeah
I know
producer alex is sitting there bitter
because dan finally showed up and so he
didn't get to do the game show did you
play these games Alex nobody grew a
beard oh okay okay well good what did
you what if your comment what did you
what did you think of is there a TD the
charity because I didn't those the one I
didn't actually have time to play so uh
pretty pretty much everything answer now
what interesting thing they do have
going for them though is zero
permissions no it is cool all right a
thumbs up to that what's impressed thank
you guys yeah all right by the way Alex
we're not to your left we're right in
front of you yeah totally okay all right
so let's go ahead Oh actually you know
what I have to I have to mention one
other thing sir is TD now this does not
apply to the full version which for all
I know is completely different and
better but you know whatever uh what is
up with this icon you don't need to put
the name of your app in the icon yeah
that's that's sort of a waste of space
so could you go to the screen right
right oh no I just switch over to the to
the tablet cuz i just want to share this
icon off because it it just kind of
special notice the actual via sure you
keep a daikon is actually pretty cool
yeah yeah it's alright it looks better
and it doesn't have the name right but
the free one yeah so it is this like the
menu look better too I you know I'm just
I'm curious I I you know no no it's
exactly the same what doesn't have the
bi thing at the top which makes it look
better but yeah well that's true I start
anything yeah yeah it's all the same it
is uh yeah okay well okay just thought
it would be worth checking out all right
well let's go ahead and move on then to
Sakura see I guess or sack racy i don't
know i'm going to God's accuracy okay so
sacristy apparently is a location-based
action RPG now I didn't play this
because as an ethereal being I have no
location but dan did yeah this is going
to be fun because uh I'm turning on
location here and I didn't actually try
the location
mock locations please disable all right
I'm going I'm going to go to couch mode
go back all right because so I actually
never got to see the location stuff
we're in the game and I have no idea
whether it actually adds any relevance
to the gameplay it doesn't feel like it
will but you know I you know that that's
just that being said the game is set in
this in this sort of 16-bit styled
fantasy world that we're looking at here
and has that's kind of cool and it has
touch controls that move you ever so
slowly through the board and and because
of this case it's just one of those
games that advertises there's like 30
hours of gameplay and 29 of them are
spent walking yeah you know and I'm here
at this temple and you say I just killed
off someone it doesn't actually go
through explaining how to actually play
the game it has a tutorial that explains
what you're supposed to do next like so
he says you go through it's like all
right now find the skeleton and kill him
but doesn't actually explain how it
turns out isn't that just like an old
dude so this is like some random senior
citizen that you just killed it's not
clear why that guy is Atef was attacking
me he might you know oh he was attacking
you is that what your yeah yeah he was I
just offense anyway yeah oh now that
looks like a zombie I'm not maybe a
Frankenstein it's kind of cool oh no no
it's like a zombie night I think it
looks like it looks like it might have
gotten poisoned because I'm all green
anyways the game we can actually pretty
basic you know the graphics are
definitely sort of a combination and
they kind of remind me of kind of like
Ultima 5 or Ultima 6 you know what yeah
this is actually I think this is the
first game of this sort that have
actually liked the graphics because
usually my attitude is like okay dude if
you're gonna go retro go full retro
because if you go retro but high res it
just ends up looking stupid but these
guys totally pulled it off it looks
retro and yet it's really high res and
it looks good yeah and you know there's
there's lots of really really nice
touches in the graphics of this game and
I'm really digging that temple that's
right under my arm yeah move over so it
gets a seed so the viewers can actually
see it yeah so yes that looks cool so um
you
while the game did drive me crazy with
the sort of the actual play of the game
and they're very very slow pacing of
these early scenes and the sort of semi
bewildered state of what I'm supposed to
be doing in the I assume you're supposed
to be killing everything and then taking
whatever is not nailed down can you go
inside the temple not that I was able to
to actually find out I tried doing it it
didn't seem like I could go down is that
dude associated with the temple is like
a fryer or something don't kill him you
know I know that's the easy now I know
ok welcome what is it that that lead you
here I say there are resurrecting
creatures just as it was predicted only
an ancient ritual can free us from this
horror so I'm going to say right now
it's for help that is pretty and I love
the font but it's not a fond it's a
bitmap and its really really small on
this device yeah yeah that's what it
definitely it actually might be you
thought but it's if it is it's being
rendered really small yeah it's its
location I can't actually tell the rest
of the UI is actually I would say it's
as small as it possibly could be but
it's not too small yeah it actually
works pretty well on the screen what's
kind of cool about this game and I'll
try not to lose hdmi in this maybe we
can't do it here is it done oh yeah you
can't rotate rotate water so this will
this game watch you playing both
portrait and landscape acid yeah that's
nice yeah and it should right i mean why
wouldn't a game like this be able to
play now we does have audio on the lock
screen i will say that which was made me
kind of sad yeah and and we gettin
beatin that drum for a long time audio
when you leave the application oh yeah
yeah yeah there are a ton of people
complaining about this I and this is an
example of sight like we get really
really anal about things like no audio
lock screen that you know there's
there's good reasons for that but but
you nobody's really really anal about
audio and yeah yeah yeah you can't kill
the audio it's just playing all the time
if you don't exit and logout of the app
it just it keeps going until the system
accidentally kills the app for whatever
reason yeah I might want to take care of
that I think it would actually boost
your sales the the other thing to note
is that there is a theory a way to get
to other aspects of your character
without doing this
couldn't find them there's a lot of
controls that are sitting underneath the
menu key okay and there's a lot of stuff
here underneath the menu key and like
rato and I just pointed out on the last
show in the app clinic using the menu
key is problematic because it is
implemented in different ways across
different devices so if you can get rid
of it and move to either an on-screen
button or an action bar pattern or
something else that is predictable
that's what we would recommend at this
point yeah I mean given given that you
guys have a lot of space you could be
using for to pull up these kinds of new
well and they've got eight freaking
other buttons too I mean you don't like
their know exactly if not likely this is
of me this is a devoid of buttons but
that the main problem with this is that
they're just not very discoverable and
it's actually kind of a pain to go here
and get to my inventory now they're
supposedly as a green jewel that I can
click on to get to the inventory I don't
see it but I mean jewel angel night and
I see this one but that's not a that
looks like a talk thing yes John so I'm
not so I dude what if the color that you
think is green is actually what they
think it's red dude yeah that's I
thought about that so you click on here
and you get to this backpack which is
not the inventory oh but I can't get to
it that way that's that's problem ideas
that you come up with when you're high
and never work out yeah I know I know I
know so um I maybe I don't know okay so
um so yeah you know my feeling is I
wanted the game to grab me faster with
with with a story and an engaging game
now the this d I'm really curious about
the location based stuff there is
actually and also also with a tutorial
that really explained how to play not
too kind of telling you what to do that
would I really wanted tap on the on the
skeleton you'll find the skeleton in the
map because he's blinking in the corner
you know the map will show on map of the
world around you because we're actually
in a parallel universe and that's what
we're seeing here all that girl is
that's a whole story I think that
actually is what's going on but I race
but you know I don't completely know
it's a little concerned
so I the you know there's a lot there's
a lot this this game really requires
like probably five or six hours of
defects yeah here's the other thing that
I just want to mention and and it's it's
a little NIT and you know wouldn't get
anybody fired or anything but but that's
the word temp l spelled out in Greek
characters yeah temp L mmhmm yeah you
know what if you're gonna use Greek
characters learn Greek it's not that
hard all right what is kind of hard it's
not hard at all we's you are Greek I
know yeah I'm speaking with authority
your bias way to quit put the camera on
the Greek man okay I actually want to
ask a question Alex how old were you
when you learned great I don't really
know great very well because it's hard
good at body yeah it is Greek to him
there we are all right so think think
thank you for being there as our as our
a Greek correspondent we snot often we
get to take advantage of that so uh all
right what's up let's move on because
this this this is obviously a deep game
but it's just so slow that i won't was
any any other comments you have on the
game alex is there sorry any other
comments you have in the game all right
I pretty much everything that you guys
said I found it very slow yet started I
Canada it was sort of it was like the
the Lord of the Rings thing was just a
whole lot of walking you know there's
like ninety percent walking without the
poetry right so there's a plus but other
than that yeah so this is something that
and it's also an online game by the way
right and I have also not yet gone to
the to the to the really cool online
features that I know must be better than
the chat well but this is a good point I
mean it's true that we review five games
a week we don't have the time
necessarily to put huge amounts of
effort into each one but then again
neither do the people that you're hoping
will purchase things if you know we eat
what we know we
short attention spans but so does
everyone yeah I attended to talk by John
Romero last year um and as you know i
mean so jon is obviously famous for
having a short attention span no oh
ferred for I know I know and I for ya
for for making an awesome game called
doom in a crappy one called daikatana
but you know recently he's been and I
killed lots of frogs in daikatana ok
lately he's been in the facebook space
and and he had some really really good
things to uh to say he and his wife made
a game that his title escapes me at the
moment but it is very very popular and
they pointed out that you know according
to their metrics people gave you about
30 seconds to a minute before they moved
on to the next thing Wow ok and so no
matter how deeper game is if you can't
grab someone in that amount of time it's
very very unlikely that they will give
you a second thought because there are
just so many things out there that
people can be entertained by why would
they work hard to be entertained by your
system if it takes a huge amount of
grinding when they could very easily go
to some other game and be entertained
immediately exactly yeah I know yeah i
just wanted to I wanted to get grabbed
by the story more quickly and I end and
I and definitely the movement speed was
driving me just crazy in the game and
also to be honest it's really not clear
when you're fighting when you click so
there's click to move and click the
fights you have to actually stop moving
wait for the guy to be there then
clicking once you stop moving well
that's that's just a poor in Turfan
there as you know so I really wanted the
interface to be you know even though i
like the in general tap to move where
you want to go if you see the monsters
there i really want the tap to walk up
and start and start blogging yeah i
thought that was pretty obvious I mean
any Mouse based RPG that's exactly what
you do if you tap on an enemy you will
move to them and start attacking uzhe
that moves you to the position you walk
right through the enemy until that's
just nasty that was the most awkward
part for me was I click on the skeleton
we started walking toward each other and
then passed each other
arrangements are looking for low chair
wow that's like Starcraft you I all
right you know what we're we're just
gonna get madder and madder the further
we go with this let's talk about
potential which I actually really enjoy
attention super clever yeah you know I
was the guy said it was his first game
uh yeah and it's it's certainly a simple
game but it's very well executed so the
idea with potential is that you were
going to um are you coming even switch
their er yeah exactly yeah you're going
to go ahead and draw a shape and these
are mostly they start out a sort of
Tetris Shamu shimmer cha-cha Munoz uh
but you can draw them in any orientation
which honestly was the one thing I
didn't like because it meant I had to do
a lot of drawing and sometimes I get it
wrong but as an interface there's a
couple things that are really good about
it first it's very reactive it's got
this particle system which means
absolutely nothing but it's kind of cool
yeah and it shows you where you're
drawing it's just it's really really
good at that and then what's clever
about it is you're trying to fill space
so no matter what shape things are the
idea is you need to put them together so
that you can get these things too and if
you win crazy rectangles or squares the
internet that's your goal right well and
you're trying to fill the entire the
entirety of the board mm-hmm and if you
can um yeah if you can make a square for
instance like this well almost like that
let's see I think I'm going to need a
new shape there
darn it see this is where I would love
to have like better you know
intelligence of some kind why am i
everything I draw doesn't work ok there
we go all right yeah help me out here
man so also you have to think about that
block you can only draw it in the four
rotated orkut orientations for that
block right so you see you can't
unfortunately it's a little it's a
little gift to do you do have to think
back to the Block in its physical shape
rather than just it's so that it's you
can't draw its flipped orientation
basically right exactly you you have to
just drop rotated and so yeah for me
because I'm handicapped that way it was
a little more difficult which is weird
cuz i did so well on the ASVAB like the
spatial rotation stuff i don't know
maybe it's just anyway but I'm so now
laying the alcohol right there you go
now I'm gonna see that that made me a
huge rectangle and one thing that's kind
of cool about this is that while that
rectangles building i can actually make
it bigger yeah that's it that is really
cool so i don't know if that actually
helps anything but i can do it and then
as long as i wait for it to fill up it
gives me more score now that doesn't
seem like a big deal and a level like
this but in a level where you have very
little space and very little time that's
kind of a big deal do you wait for it to
fill up or do you tap it immediately to
get less score but more space mm-hmm as
you on the levels get more and more
difficult and you start moving from
these tetra munoz to more and more weird
and interesting shapes some of them are
quite frustrating mm-hmm and very very
large game board so actually I think I i
have to admit after several hours of
play I think I i ended up crapping out
on a level 4 or 5 which was gigantic it
was almost impossible to fill in the
time they gave you the same night that I
thought I'd like I know I was drawing
that correctly so I just didn't register
my draw no the the other thing that's
interesting is you'll notice that some
of these little blocks have cracks in
them
and that becomes important later on
because those will get removed if you
dont have space those are what they call
leftovers which are just you know once
you've drawn something mm-hmm I if part
of the shape forms a rectangle mm-hmm
and the rest of them don't like these
these two right here gosh I those are
now going to turn into leftovers and if
you run out of space those will get
removed and if that happens you'll get
more space but your eye your score
multiplier will get reset right now
you're a score multiplier to and would
get reset back to one next board I'm not
right and that's because you covered
fifty percent of the board or more yeah
so I can tell is Tony yeah we were both
you know so I would like to see them get
rid of the compatibility button in the
zoom and the zoom thing in time right
yeah if you look down at the bottom lets
you know of the screen you can see a lot
of things going wrong that shouldn't be
going wrong but overall and and and of
course on this Asus Transformer Prime
the UI up in the upper left hand corner
is much smaller than it needs to be its
verging on not being readable you also
do need a pretty hefty manual you need i
had to reread the instructions several
times before i understood what was going
on and i would say that a more
professional game would have introduced
all of the concepts to me via tutorials
he was rather than just kind of throwing
me it's the only reason I knew what I
was doing was when I watched the video
and and that that was super super
helpful but I see that's the thing I
never watched videos why because they're
complete waste of time why would anyone
watch a video so I'm all right okay well
we never get to this unfortunately we're
almost to the next time yeah we didn't
bring the charger right so I yeah
potential oh look at that so potentially
had good a good feature graphic block
dropping puzzle game reinvented for
touchscreen will not be legible if
potential is featured on a phone so
that's one thing that you want to look
at also also that that icon really do we
really
eat around a rectangle no you don't at
all actually it you know I so I i I'd
love to see you got you come up with
some other theme others well at least
it's not as bad as the offroad legends
icon that's which has chrome around it
although since it's about monster trucks
allow the chrome yeah and actually like
the fact that thing that though that the
dust actually covers up the chrome as if
it were real you know that is toy you
should pop out right okay so yeah these
guys did ever now the offroad legends
icon there or the title should be larger
for future graphic we usually recommend
that it covers about fifty percent of
the available pixels so it should be
like slices big yeah it's got to be at
least a third the height of it if it's
smaller than a third to hide of it we
say it's going to be an illegible and so
you know it would i would say if it if
it were a good twenty five percent
bigger it would get least be kind of the
minimum acceptable size that this is
offroad legends by dog bite games i mean
how much more masculine can you get
exactly he's actually i like their i
really like their other game is 8-bit
ninja yet maybe kind of laugh if I was
looking at like this is a fairly
radically different kind of games yeah
actually bring it up yeah let's take a
look at this so uh awkward legends a
very polished g'day I'm score loop and
say no do you like fun no score leap
doesn't ask if you like fun no I know it
doesn't oh no no it's bringing up tapjoy
adds all right really yeah oh I didn't
get it with that maybe my oh I do like
what isn't it is that not the awesome
that is pretty sweet I know not exactly
a monster truck though you I know there
we are you've got quite an accomplished
garage my friend uh no that's because I
that's because I pretend to go and
review the game you get you get that you
get the truck you get that if you if you
hit the they gave you an incentive for
reviewing the game yeah so they didn't
actually say what could get a room they
didn't say what kind of you to get up to
get the wood it just said review the
game and get this I'm like cool so I
click the button and then I went back
and I got this which is kind of
okay so go ahead ok now the bummer is
that is it is that I can't actually
choose that bus for the monster warm-up
but that sucks I know I know but this
game is has got pretty good visuals for
you know for the style of game it is
which is you know kind of this a web
style of you know track yeah it's like a
four button you know basically I have to
ask of the wheels on this truck filled
with helium because i'm not sure that
those physics are legit ah that's
because you don't live in America my
friend you'll learn yeah monstered Mont
this this this has monster truck physics
yeah kind of physics we invented here
monster trucks are completely different
from other trucks they're monstrous the
thing oh yeah there we are you have to
have you have to have gratuitous and
unnecessary the pictures of people who
look like danica patrick in your game
that's right so America I'm thinking I'm
thinking godaddy right now right why I'm
thinking my behalf of the racing games
in the world honestly but I'll tell you
what sets this apart is not only do they
have a fairly good set uh not not
perfect the presentation is not perfect
there's a few kind of cheesy icons and
some its radiance that look really
really out of place but in general
especially in the game yeah it looks
great uh and unlike many of the racing
games that we've reviewed they have some
great crash physics mm-hmm they really
really do yeah yeah give us a crash give
us crash crash for daddy ooh no that's
nice Abrash crash whole this is a good
one here we are oh there you go yeah
yeah I don't know that the truck is a
little better I think than the car I
think they have better ya better crash
model they do they do so but yeah they
now they do have some weird physics like
you is actually possible to lose a wheel
without ending the race oh wow I I know
this because last night I lost three
wheels and was in it unable to do
anything but the race was still on you
know why America uh-huh absolutely so
whoa that is awesome uh gets actually
the first time you've ever sworn on the
on the program what I think I think what
it did I swear so I know I know shocking
I totally you saying you saying you sang
the song from no i didn't okay no that
happened inside your head okay okay you
might have oh there we are you only get
to use my bus yeah i know but that's a
possible toxin we just fill in yeah so
so yeah uh I don't know what else what
else to say on this game I believe this
game also plates throw in the lock
screen as I recall I'm gonna give it a
pass would be because Americans exactly
I had it is America that's why oh man so
yeah check that out see the race is
still on dude there's nothing I can do
can I can I put the tires back on I
don't know maybe that's an in-app
purchase it totally should be da I don't
manipulate my tongue like my car anymore
can you uh can you that purchase like I
guess I can the membership wow this is
pretty sad that service I'm dice alright
alright alright I'm start um so yeah it
looks like we're gonna run out of
battery just at the right time here here
on we're already over time but this was
a great game it's yeah you know it's not
everybody's cup of tea it's honestly all
joking aside probably not my cup of tea
there's a few things that I would love
to change about it I feel like the the
difficulty is just wrong it's it's not
easy enough to get big air yet it's too
easy to land small jumps there's there's
not a lot of skill involved and maybe
maybe it's just me because I you know I
live in the Bay Area and for all my
bragging i know nothing about monster
truck physics but nice okay now see
that's the thing right there I'll tell
you what really needs to happen you need
an achievement you need something that
pops up and says pancake yeah cuz that's
actually that takes in you know what
everything that I'm saying is that it
was critical I take it all back cuz that
was awesome that was so awesome all
right you know what let's go ahead and
we're never going I can already tell
that either Ian's never going driving
with me again this is a I've demonstrate
with you you drive a Prius it's true
actually all right there again we do are
we doing monster trucks together it off
early breeze yeah that's true that'd be
kind of awesome how like the jack don't
know he had friends did oh yeah you
could the other night whoa they're all
right right boom that's it yeah right so
what staff right hit it through the jo
ooo yeah I forgot I did this for Dan
watch we're done oh man flame effect
that's awesome and this game that worked
so well after after off road that was
right oh yeah yeah walk wolf well
definitely I can't wait to see you do
with after effects now you know we could
we could I know right it's gonna be
incredible alright so wait wait wait
look check this out what happened I
poured myself a second glass no okay I
was going to say important to zero
you've not given Alex an easier yet
thank you sir Wow
yeah I now this is what I've been
randomly muting you throughout the show
makes us do so Alex I have a producer
alex how did the youtube comment stream
go yes actually we have from the
developer of pearls yeah who's also
avoided the developer of envision of the
veggies which we do all right who
reviewed a couple months ago he says he
updated the feature graphic and should
be up soon awesome to get our feedback I
don't look like it's refreshed yet and
uh but as far as developers an
absolutely reviewed on the show is by
far the fastest turnaround the fastest
feedback loop yeah yeah I God well we
this is the second time Wally comment on
the thing he says eight hey I can fix
that nice well I think it's a good game
and it's one of those games it's it's
hard yeah it is fun to pick em play well
actually that's a good point actually if
you're still listening um so bubble
popping games are incredibly popular and
they are hey rato you can switch to me
anytime you want I'm the prettier one I
actually yeah that's I I actually kind
of like it on yeah I thank you we're
actually we're still totally scoring
points with our Greek audience now gosh
anyway what I was trying to say is if
you're still listening the bubble
popping game audience um excuse older
and female and is almost certainly not
an audience that's looking for a really
high stress game also I play them a lot
despite not being female or anyway the
point is it to destress the point is
that you do need to make sure you've got
a learning learning curve on these
things that are the isn't gonna
completely frustrate your audience yeah
that was but I would say that was my one
comment about the game as I sort of I
sort of wanted there to be sort of an
easy in moment and because of the design
of the puzzles it is actually kind of
tricky to do that but
I think I think it's possible then well
the other thing that i would suggest
that i think would improve the game is
it it did take me a few times before i
understood what the rules were drawing
the line through the pearls and the game
does a pretty good job of it it doesn't
it's not bad but i think it could really
be improved with a few examples where
you actually just draw the line before
the user yeah definitely definitely so
all right anything else on the youtube
there alex producer alex executive
producer alex all's Quiet on the YouTube
front well you guys suck yeah alright so
that's our show for today's our audience
that's what we do here not on the Friday
well actually that's exactly what we do
we eat Igor says I think I'll be getting
hammered tonight sorry not me i was
thinking of Ian yeah right right who's
got two thumbs and needs to go to AAA
that guy now all right actually I've
been babysitting my baby daughter all
week my wife is out of town she's in
Shanghai on business I hopefully she's
bringing some some cool stuff back for
the household boy I hope so I could use
some more of those ceramic knives I'll
tell you that well sure I guys are
kidding aren't they good really hot all
right so after me all right well that is
our show thanks very much for joining us
on the Friday games review we will be
back next week with another open topic
we'll see how this goes yeah there's a
lot of other stuff in this town topic
from this week too right just remember
that unlike before we are refreshing the
topic each week so if you nominated
something this week and it didn't get
chosen you do need to Reno minate it for
next week in order for it to be
considered again absolutely and we'll
probably at some point I have some
themes as well again you know I think
that think the current font is it will
will actually always take some some
random game so we don't have to have
someone waits for you know six months
but ill we get back to the theme again
because a lot of people want us to look
at they're getting
but also you know we do really really
like the idea of being able to theme
some of the shows we've also talked
about a few other options i'd love to
get some feedback from our viewers
absolutely for instance we've discussed
the possibility of talking about the
games that are going to be featured that
week why they were featured what they
have in common we've talked about maybe
looking at games from unknown developers
or maybe even previewing games from
known developers you might be excited
about let us know what you're interested
in we'd love to yeah make this show more
valuable to you and I wouldn't want out
what I really want actually at some
point is to do it as to do a show where
where people nominate games that they
wish were better wouldn't it be kind of
cool that would be an excellent that's
one thing that we have talked about
doing maybe a game clinic because we
have money of tools here we we look at
games in very in-depth ways all the time
you're trying to figure out how their
draw order and their texturing and their
resources and their geometry if any of
the slimmest suck less yeah we do it all
the time we would love to kind of switch
into that mode I think so let us know
what you think and to all our drunk
friends in Austria hey and we're that's
so cool do you want to do mirror yeah
all right so anyway it's been good
chatting with you on the friday game
review and we will see you next week at
our new time right we have a new time do
we have any time I I did guys sure um
next week make sure you check our
Google+ page because there may be a new
time and if there is you do not want to
miss that that's right alright thanks
everyone take care